[Music]
this just happened now you are a
superstar in your own right but you got
to play with the Rolling Stones I did
you got to be a part of that band you
know that's just I mean think we have a
picture here this just happened the
other night unless this is photoshopped
or there's a car down there you can get
those on the promenade
how did this happen first of all how do
you get to play with the Rolling Stones
um
Mick told me literally and and and said
you know you want to sit in with us and
and I said let me think about it and did
you put him on hold that was been great
I was fantastic and he said he wanted to
do respectable and and before I knew
what I was it was at soundcheck at the
at the arena and we did respectable it
was amazing that's fantastic now do they
all show up for soundcheck
I mean I'm thinking at this point you
think they'd know their material well it
was that it was the first show of the
tour and um and Gwen Stefani was sitting
in as well and and so they ran all these
songs they soundcheck for Nellie it must
have been two hours
close to two hours they played all of
them and then took a break of course and
then they did their two and a half hour
show it was amazing their stamina is is
insane what's the point where your soul
leaves your body and you just think I
can't believe this is happening is it
when you're playing guitar next to Keith
Richards or when you're singing next to
Mick Jagger or some combination above it
all of it I mean just to look around to
see Charlie what's back there is insane
it was it was amazing and Mick has such
ferocity when he sings I mean to be
inches away from him he's also the fact
that he's in such amazing shape right
someone he's in incredible he's like 120
years old and he's just no I really is
he fought the Civil War
he's English which makes no sense he
just wanted to be part of that battle
but but apparently he runs like you know
20 miles a day or something he's an
incredible yeah great krycek had you
ever played in a rock band before
because you're a country music well I
played in rock band for about a week I
was I started playing guitar when I was
six and I grew up playing country music
when I was about 15 friend of mine was
in a band and he wanted to be the singer
so he said I want you to be the guitar
player Bam's called fractured mirror
right and it was a heavy metal band you
were a heavy metal band yeah for about a
week and and they did like Judas Priest
scorpion Saxon Black Sabbath the list
off right so I joined a band and I've
got my my strat and when Marshall amp
and everything but I just discovered
this guy called Ricky Skaggs yeah and I
loved his records and so we're playing
like a Judas Priest song and they throw
me the solo and I'm like some wine they
could pick it all this chicken pickin
guitar
I had an identity crisis at a young age
do they kick you out did they say you
got to get hired me Wow yeah that was
our stage that was the end of it